what is the cow opening the cow opening
is basically a setup regardless of what
the opponent plays you put your Knights
on B3 and G3
so these are like the others
and then
[Music]
gradually you produce some milk
hopefully don't get turned into beef
so we'll have one game
to wrap up the stream playing a fide
master
pre-move I could pre-move it
the nice thing about the cow like you
don't really have to think in the
opening too much
you just play these moves and say moo
hopefully okay I can't remove Knight G6
though
that's slightly annoying
this will be a modified cow
G5 included
genetically modified
I have to turn this into a giga cow
this actually is a nice Improvement look
at this
the cow is becoming stronger
non-domesticated
[Music]
I still have to develop my Bishop here I
kind of want to develop it here
although maybe maybe this has some logic
G4 first
oh
wait what's Happening Here
do I undo my cow
probably
I don't want to take
and the
yeah I don't know what creature this is
now but
it's something maybe this move
in this Bishop D3 is coming
take take
I think this is okay
foreign
I still haven't developed my Bishops
but that's okay
uh
in this move
oh no
let's play this move
I'm suffering the consequences here
at least this is something
okay don't hurt me
I think my king will stay in the center
maybe it will slide over
F3 is a good move
I have this move
so if takes do I take with Rook
Maybe
maybe not though
am I kind of
[Music]
D5 perhaps
okay this is about to turn into a bullet
game
D5 is a blunder
opponent didn't take the pawn though
well have I plundered this Pawn
but it's all a Gambit
King returns to the center
Thank you new sub
wow
take
G3 may be coming
I'm sorry remember I lost casting rights
so I can't actually Castle queenside but
maybe I can manually Castle
[Music]
fixing my Pawn structure
not super Pleasant
um
I want to play this and this
okay this is a big achievement
trade off my sad Bishop
play this
might have take so I take here
moo
cows becoming aggressive now now I take
look at my amazing cow
it's so strong
oh I have to move quicker
we need two mate coming
uh free rook
as a mouse slip
let's go
like how is is utterly too strong
okay that's dedicated to Anna crowling
hope you enjoyed that one
I do have to go thanks everyone for
watching
I'll be back in the future I am planning
to play the cow opening in every single
game in title Tuesday
so do stay tuned and goodbye